hallo mein name ist luca und ich bin
gerade an der anderen location ich bin
wieder zu hause bei meinen eltern und
hab vergessen videos ford zu produzieren
ich bin ein dummkopf jetzt legen wir
euch das ganze jetzt ein bisschen
provisorisch heute ist natürlich frei
hat das minecraft deswegen sind wir auch
schon in minecraft drin ich geh jetzt
einfach mal auf dem server drauf
beispielsweise komme hd punkt netz da
werden wir uns jetzt erst mal schön
rhein locken und falls ihr euch fragt
hey was ist das hier für eine face cream
qualität wie es ist das vielleicht die
minecraft hier so ein bisschen anders
ich habe mir gedacht bevor ich dann hier
irgendwie drin sondern mit der eiszeit
mit der laptop kamera und etwa mache man
einfach mal so ein video ich zocke ne
runde gemeinschaft auf dem laptop und
ich habe keine maus das heißt ich spiele
hier gerade ich komme ich beweise waren
alle die das hier nicht glauben so sieht
das er gerade aus ich spiele mit dem
trackpad heißt das trackpad das jetzt
quasi für mich selber auch so eine
kleine herausforderung also minecraft
nur mit dem trackpad spiel in einem
laptop und wir machen das ganze bitte
erstmal ein bisschen heller und ich
entschuldige mich für ein scheiß
qualität für scheiß ton für für alles
einfach das tut mir leid ich habe
vergessen vorzubeugen
deswegen kommt jetzt so was wir spielen
einfach mal eine runde etwas und zwar
gehe ich mal hier ein dings rhein in
sind wir gerade im bett was überhaupt
hier sind team orange und es ist ein 8 x
18 leute die gegen das spiel jeder eine
eigene insel was schauen wir dann nicht
überleben werde ich das ganze ding
gewinnen sollte werde ich hier live vor
der kamera
meine iphone hülle essen übrigens wie
findet ihr das ich habe das mal so
testweise was genau ich glaube ich dir
erstmal defensiv vor ort so wie ich mich
kenne kommen direkt alle zu mir und
wollen mich umbringen
ich dachte ich muss nächsten aber ich
muss nicht kelders ich hasse das wenn
man noch nicht lesen kann so wir waren
hier erstmal schön unser bett einer
mutter natürlich keiner direkt ankommen
kann und uns töten kann sondern erstmal
diesen blöcken hier vorbei muss so hier
noch ich habe schon länger überlegt ob
ich habe sogar nicht mehr mein inventar
geöffnet so weit ist es hallo ich
einfach halte ich ich bekomme wie wäre
es wenn einmal die sounds reiser machst
wenn bet zerstört wird
jetzt ist der moment angegliedert ist er
ist gestorben
ok freude ich habe keine steuern mehr
das heißt ich habe mir mal wieder zurück
hier bronze
ich muss wohl niemanden naseputzen
schade und herzlich willkommen bei einem
video von crafter der einzige youtuber
der bitten im video oben läuft sich die
nase putzen und unverschämter weise sind
wir noch am leben ist die quali ist
tatsächlich ganz nice oder also ich sehe
das jetzt gerade durch den bildschirmen
gedreht haben kannst du dann mal mein
pickel hier
hey was soll ich denn jetzt hier machen
ich weiß natürlich wie betis läuft und
dass ich in die mitte gehen soll oder so
aber ich hab doch im länderkampf
überhaupt gar keine chance schaut euch
das aber an ich stehe hier und macht
hier mit ja okay ihr könnt nicht sehen
weil die nur mal fresse ertragen müssen
ich spiele hier gerade halt wirklich wie
sollen [ __ ]
das ist echt nicht mehr schön es ist der
methodisten los der stimmen wie die
ganze zeit von alleine schoppe das ist
schon das ja ist das zweite mal jetzt
hype im vortex abonniert meinen kanal
nein nein nein nein
scheiße da konnte warum der antrag doch
andere an die ich mich okay der dummkopf
geht jetzt zu meinem bett das ist aber
gar kein problem weil mein name wurde
damit das nicht bei dieser einen letzten
runde etwas bleibt und packe ich hier
direkt eine runde richmont dran das ist
ein modus wo ist die richtig krass zu
geht also immer dann hat ich habe kein
ehrlich gesagt überhaupt kein plan
wieder funktioniert ich habe ja man hat
irgendwie einen fall und muss danach
wenn man den nicht mehr hat muss man
dann die schere und das messer oder
nehmen die computex benutzen
ich habe mich mit comics in lucka bitten
des lokals
das blatt scheint sich zu wenden freunde
ich bin nur viertletzter h6 gebets hallo
da stand gerade wo wir aufnahme wurde
automatisch angehalten jetzt jetzt
müsste mich ist klar dass ich dann
fragen wollte war ob ihr mal wieder
öfter minecraft sehen wollen weil dieser
modus hier tatsächlich macht spaß den
tod wieso es hier schild auf dem grünen
stets wollen wir gehen jetzt auf
gefahren klar eins aufs maul durch doch
einen kilmer und ich weiß nicht wieder
doch wieso schreibst du nicht kannst
nicht mal friedliche wo die in minecraft
geben so was wie ich wir backen alle
zusammen einen kuchen und essen den
danach oder so denn wenn ich einen
server machen würde dann ist der kuchen
server kann ich hier die dings
hochklettern
diese komplette fassade weil das gibt
gerade sehr stark danach lud kletterer
kann ich die frau hoffmann was soll denn
das wiso sterbe ich denn im schatten
geheim
ich habe in seinem gebäude gerade einen
weg gefunden habe ich finde das gebäude
nicht mehr
es ist unfassbar traurig lade die kriege
ich meine dass der code 1337 ist es
jetzt sehr offen was habe ich denn jetzt
hier gemacht hat ist das jetzt hier ist
jetzt im raum offen gegangen habe ich
jetzt irgendwas bekommen extra leben
oder ein pfeil oder nähe nichts
aufgefallen kopf sieht sehr schön aus
der spieler julian broad range mord
gewonnen die auf jeden fall riesig als
die filter wurde ich ich würde auch
keine ahnung wer das video gefahren hat
zeigt
es tut mir leid dass das ganze von der
qualität vielleicht nicht so toll war
aber eigentlich sind ja alle meine
videos schlecht wirst du nicht sagen wen
wir uns in einem nächsten video wieder
und morgen erstmal in einem live video
die nächsten gaming videos werden dann
wieder ein bisschen durchstrukturiert
haben mit besserer sound quali
videoqualität die cetera aber ich war
halt echt gerade hier ne das ist so habe
ich aufgenommen und jetzt sehen wir uns
irgendwann später wieder euro kamera
handy